how's it going everybody it's Warren and
this past week has certainly been a
treat for us we've gotten plenty of
phase four and phase five weeks
including plot leaks and new
announcements of new movies that are
coming to phase five and not to mention
some Disney Plus leaks as well as it has
been revealed that an Inhumans Disney
Plus show could be in development right
now but quite possibly one of the
biggest news in most exciting news that
we've gotten over this past week is that
ant-man three is currently in
development and it's not in development
for a Disney Plus show like it's been
reported could happen it's in
development for a third movie this comes
as no surprise because the ant-man
franchise has done extremely well for
its franchise and their films that many
many fans love especially the younger
fans of Marvel and that actually leads
us in today's video because there's been
a brand new report that states that
ant-man 3 is going to set up the Young
Avengers to come in the MCU before we
dive into this breakdown be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 all you have to do to enter
is be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain so again
the news that ant-man three is returning
to the big screen and not a show for
Disney Plus has gotten many fans excited
but now we have even more reasons to be
excited about the third ant-man film
coming to theaters because during a
recent edition of Murphy's Law podcast
Charles Murphy claimed that the three
cool could end up introducing the Young
Avengers and if you think about it this
makes perfect sense because Avengers in
game really did set up the Young
Avengers quite perfectly especially in
regards to ant-man / Scott Lang's
daughter Cassie Lang who goes on to be
stature in the comics now as we saw an
Avengers in game Cassie Lang survived
the snap and was aged five years older
in fact Scott Lang barely recognized his
daughter when he was reunited with her
in Avengers in game and of course as we
know from the other ant-man film's
Cassie Lang is more than willing to
become a superhero
in fact it's something that she really
wants to do so no doubt she was ready to
take on the mantle of stature ain't not
to mention we have recently learned that
Wiccan and speed the children of Wanda
and vision are set to appear in the
Wanda vision series for Disney Plus
recently it has been revealed that they
are casting two babies for the show and
of course since one a maksimov and
vision have two babies in the comics it
only makes sense that they are casting
for their children Wiccan and speed and
not to mention a recent plot leak says
that Wiccan is going to play a big role
in Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness including his mother Wanda as
well so that's two new superheroes to
add to the Young Avengers roster as well
and not to mention miss Marvel is on her
way as well miss Marvel was officially
announced and confirmed at Disney's d23
event to be getting her own Disney Plus
show in what is believed to be phase
four and of course as we already know
the Hawkeye series has been announced
for Disney and Plus in phase four which
is going to set up Kate
Bishop to take on the mantle of Hawkeye
now I know there's been a lot of talk
recently about the Hawkeye series given
the allegations against Jeremy Renner
and a lot of people are saying that he
may not come back to reprise his role as
Hawkeye but he most likely will and even
if he doesn't the hot guys series is
still going to continue and set up Kate
Bishop so we most likely don't have
anything to worry about Jeremy Renner
will most likely come back to play
Hawkeye in the Hawkeye series but if
anything Kate Bishop is still going to
be set up from the series so that's
going to add Kate Bishop as Hawkeye to
the Young Avengers roster and then of
course we can't forget young Harley
Kiner who was there at the end of
Avengers in Game four Tony Stark's
funeral and as we all know Marvel
doesn't really do anything accidentally
or do anything without a bigger purpose
yes it's nice to have Harley Kiner there
for Tony Stark's funeral but that means
they kept in touch since the events of
Iron Man 3 Harley keiner and Tony Stark
have clearly kept in contact with each
other because Marvel isn't going to put
Harley keiner
at the end of Avengers in game at Tony
Stark's funeral unless there is a bigger
purpose for him coming up yes it's a
nice sentiment but they haven't spoken
in many many years it would have been
just as easy to leave him out but again
Marvel does everything on purpose so he
is most likely going to play iron lad
and the Young Avengers so as of right
now this is looking to be our young
Avengers roster we have stature Wiccan
and speed miss Marvel Kate Bishop and
iron lad which is a pretty great roster
and again as of recent reports thanks to
Charles Murphy's podcast ant-man 3 could
be the film to set up the Young Avengers
and of course Ant Man 3 is going to be
coming in phase 5 so the Young Avengers
could be introduced as early on as phase
5 which is great news because seeing the
young Avengers and the MC will be a nice
refreshing change from what we've seen
so far so let me know how
excited you are about this news let me
know how excited you are to finally see
an ant-man 3 film and let me know how
excited you are to see The Young
Avengers possibly set up in ant-man 3
for phase 5 let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe to my channel like
the video and comment with your favorite
superhero or villain so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 and of course subscribe so you
can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof